it was Jeff Ryman this is Anna
mcLaughlin we're coming at you with
another nerd wars this one I'll tie here
versus daredevil oh my god I am going to
win so easy as always I would be taking
the superhero daredevil and I'm gonna
get gas and I'm gonna be taking I'll tie
here from Assassin's Creed because well
I like in my ass kicked because he's emo
alright daredevil has spandex but all
Tiger has Renaissance clothing and
Renaissance clothing is by far less gay
than spandex
clearly Jeff has never been to a
Renaissance Festival yes I have and let
me tell you those people are cool I
don't know if you know my friend Marc
actually goes all the time he'd bring
this family it's this bro you know I've
really kind of would want to go to a
Renaissance so lame so lame I caught him
in a lie really every the point I'll tie
here no that's at a point at a point
that's a point for health I own number
one all right say what you will about
Renaissance attire uh-huh Daredevils
outfit much cooler spandex spandex is
much cooler which you can only get away
with your fly man it's like have you
seen Stevie Wonder's outfits Stevie
Wonder you have a boy like yes by
someone who's playing a practical joke
as does daredevil look seriously this
looks good sir put it on daredevil uses
his sonar in order to pick the perfect
costume that's why I stopped wearing the
the yellow and black yellow and black
makes more noise than red well if
they're they were pretty loud colors
can't believe that argument let's go
back to facts all right all tire has the
knowledge of every previous assassin and
the skills of every assassin before and
the all Thai airline has now figured out
how to go through time they're gonna go
back in time to a time that their asses
will be kicked by daredevil up back in
time when daredevil had sight here here
didn't have sonar where he was like 12
that's fine let's shank him right there
okay well I think generations of
assassins would know to kill him before
he got powerful in
that case why is assassin screen even a
game why can't I just go back in time to
when all these people are babies and
killed him attempt be boring as a game
exactly and that's a boring fight so
we're gonna talk about daredevil the guy
from Assassin's Creed in you know
present-day and I'm running this as many
times as I've said I'll tie here he
still doesn't know his name I'll tie
here so yeah I said it
here's the thing all right all Tigers
only thing is sneaking up on people like
a douche all right daredevil has Sonic
yes sonic hearing he he sees radar hey
you wanna sit you wonder how that fight
would go down and you'd be daredevil
alright hey I see you right there no no
it's not just one that is not a wig I'll
tell you're just well I'm not me I don't
know if you know I'll tear was bald no
he's not but here's in my number one
couldn't sneak up on daredevil number
two daredevil number two daredevil is an
accomplished martial artist and he's our
Assassin's you don't do you think
assassins are just sitting there yoga
but number three downward dog number
three though he is at the epitome of
human physical condition like him him
and Captain America are like almost par
on fighting ability
I'm glad you named the two gayest DC
characters right there they're not DC
characters go play your Nintendo play
some Sonic the Hedgehog on Nintendo i
have i love make you more Madden so
anyway we're gonna give this one to I'll
tell you no we're not it has no it's a
total one-sided fight dare don't you're
right I'll tell you would win daredevil
would you know what Ben Affleck could
beat up all tie year Ben Affleck is
there no Ben Affleck
well sittin on sittin on the couch
voyeur you don't know Damon is met
an assassin and he's just been getting
close to Ben Affleck the whole time so
you you know what that would be awesome
if Matt Damon's listening to this please
kill Ben Affleck so if you have
suggestions put them in the comments
we'd love to do them
we'll keep arguing them as long as you
keep putting them up and if you start
hating them well we'll blame it on Adam
thanks guys
you